said yourself then you have said on the
website for your original website for
the Huskers University that you
emotionally manipulated women to fall in
love with you so that you could get them
working in the sex industry for your
financial gain as I said I have to be
very careful with what I say but let's
put it this way no women are coming out
against me and accusing me of doing yes
they are no they're not yes they are no
they're not who there's testimony from
the current investigation the current
investigation which I cannot discuss
which I know intimately and you don't I
can tell you right now that the the
women who are in this case File there
are two American women who have been
caught already admitting their ly and
then nobody else is accusing me of
anything